una recompensa de 25 mil millones de
dólares por su cabeza diez años después
de la muerte de osama bin laden ayman
al-zawahiri murió en un ataque con
aviones no tripulados llevado a cabo por
eeuu en afganistán
ahora se ha hecho justicia y este líder
terrorista ya no existe no importa el
tiempo que tome no importa donde se
escondan si son una amenaza para nuestro
pueblo eeuu los encontrará y eliminarán
find you / médico egipcio en su juventud
radical hizo rápidamente huyó de egipto
a mediados de la década de 1980 encontró
refugio en la ciudad paquistaní de
peshawar y ayudó a los combatientes
yihadistas muy ágil y no allí fue donde
conoció a osama bin-laden juntos
fundaron al qaeda y trabajaron varios
atentados mortales incluyendo los
ataques del 11 de septiembre que mataron
a casi 3.000 personas en nueva york en
2001 a las familias que perdieron padres
y madres maridos esposas hijos e hijas
hermanos y hermanas amigos y compañeros
de trabajo en aquel abrasador día de
septiembre espero que esta acción
decisiva aporte una medida más de cierre
hasta la muerte de bin laden el egipcio
siguió siendo su 'número dos' y jefe del
movimiento terrorista su muerte supone
un golpe muy duro para la organización
yihadista en un comunicado el portavoz
de los talibanes condenó al ataque
perpetrado en el suelo afgano por
estados unidos que considera viola el
derecho internacional